Рятувати океан, купуючи продукти з вживаного пластику?
Наприклад, ось ці.
Чудово! Хіба ні?
Не буває переробленого океанічного пластику.
А й справді, чи можливе друге життя пластику з океанів?
Чи це банальний, нічим не підкріплений,  маркетинг?
Ви точно бачили під час шопінгу етикетки "зроблено ресайклінгом".
А найкрутіші - зроблено з пластику з морського дна.
Coca Cola дуже, дуже любить використовувати океанічний пластик…
у своєму маркетингу.
Adidas - теж! Ось кеди Ocean Ultraboost.  Реклама переконує,
що я можу справді врятувати море, якщо куплю нові кеди або вип'ю колу.
Але якщо придивитися ближче, виявляється, що там лише частинка пластику,
який дійсно виловлюють з моря.
Якщо пластик потрапляє у море, зібрати його звідти дуже складно.
Навіть той, що біля морської поверхні.
Добре було б, якби все було так просто. Але… сюрприз! Це зовсім не так!
Звичайно, можна задіяти човни, які будуть виловлювати пластик, але це дуже дорого.
Мільйони тонн пластику вже у морі - більшість човнів збирають
щонайбільше дві тонни на день.
Важко це дається навіть проєктам, які отримують мільйони доларів субсидій.
Цей шланг мав виудити 90% пластикових відходів з моря.
Не спрацювало. Його тепер використовують у річках.
А коли океанічний пластик на поверхні, потрібно розділити десятки різновидів.
Як ці риболовні сітки, які професорка Ґілліан Ґерке
хоче переробити на сировину для свого дослідження.
Це вдалося. Що тепер?
Ця купа вже розсортована, але все ще хаотично.
Треба розділяти далі! Нам потрібні блакитні.
Окей, блакитні ліворуч.
Сортувати сітки за фарбами, гаразд. Але для ресайклінгу ми повинні
ще подрібнити їх. Та ці сітки дуже витривалі.
Враження, наче ці ножиці з дерева...
Навіть ресайклінг звичайних побутових відходів важкий.
Я демонстрував це у своєму останньому відео.
Але це - ще важче.
Адже, перш за все, пластик у морі змінюється під впливом солі та сонячного світла.
Він стає зовсім іншим, ніж був спочатку.
Ґерке: Наступний крок - позбутися бруду.
Якщо всередині мізерні піщинки або з уламки ракушок -
такий пластик ресайклінгу не піддається.
Ґерке: Ресайклер може переробити близько 5% забруднень. Якщо ми надаємо
цей матеріал комусь, хто робитиме з нього гранули, він ставить умову -
не більше 5% забруднень! А це - дуже і дуже чисто.
Навіть після промислового очищення мікроскопічно маленькі
піщинки все одно можуть залишатися.
Ось чому продукти часто складаються з морського пластику
ТА ІНШИХ перероблених матеріалів.
А "океанічний" пластик може при цьому складати мізерну частку.
Реклама ж подає все навпаки.
Усі ці продукти робляться з нейлону фірми Econyl.
Фірма позиціонує свою тканину так, наче вона зі справжнього морського сміття -
як-от з таких загублених рибальських сіток.
Вироби Econyl рекламуються таким чином,
немовби їх виготовляють "з морського сміття" або з цих сіток.
Але у продуктах дуже-дуже мала частка риболовних відходів -
менше відсотка або навіть одна десята відсотка.
Морська екологиня Андреа Штольте вже кілька разів
контактувала з Econyl через цей сумнівний маркетинг.
В одному з мейлів Econyl написала мені, що лише "маленька частина" її тканини
складається з океанічного пластику.
Для наступного кроку з ресайклінгу ми використали
підготовлений заздалегідь матеріал. Інакше б ми різали цілий день.
З цих пластикових гранул було виготовлено відкривач листів.
Наш кінцевий продукт. Після усіх цих кроків, які ви бачили,
ви можете собі уявити, наскільки дорогим є цей декоративний ніж
для відкриття листів. Десь так… близько 200 євро.
Кай: 200 євро?!
Так, це ж повністю ручна робота!
А ці продукти неручної роботи.
Їх виготовляють промисловим шляхом, але вони коштують приблизно,
як продукти не з морського пластику.
Це можливо, лише якщо використовується дуже мало пластику
або якщо він у реальності походить не з моря.
Нині загалом немає ніякого переробленого океанічного пластику.
Це Раффі Шаєр. Він - міжнародний продавець так званого "навколоморського пластику".
Мається на увазі пластикове сміття, яке знайшли на відстані до 50 кілометрів
від узбережжя і яке, ймовірно, колись потрапить у море.
Здебільшого у країнах з поганою утилізацією сміття.
Найуважніші з нас можуть знайти це поняття на вебсторінках багатьох компаній.
Пластик з суші, але з території неподалік від узбережжя - він є скрізь.
Його набагато простіше збирати та переробляти, ніж пластик,
який справді був у морі. А головне - дешевше.
Скільки коштує одна тонна звідси?
Новий пластик коштує 762 євро за тонну,
пластик з ресайклінгу - близько 870 євро.
Ціна пластику з суші поблизу моря - десь близько 920 євро.
І все ж, порівняно зі справжнім океанічним, відносно дешево.
Згайдаймо ніж для листів за 200 євро… Собівартість стає набагато вищою,
якщо задіяти реальний океанічний пластик.
Для підприємств немає причин маніпулювати з маркетингом.
Очистка узбережжя нам так чи інакше до серця. Навіщо створювати враження,
що пластик з моря? Треба просто бути щирими і постачати, що обіцяєш.
Adidas продають свої кеди Ocean Ultraboost як зроблені "справді з океанічного пластику",
хоча насправді вони вироблені з пластику з місцевості поблизу моря.
Навіть невеликим підприємствам складно з'ясувати,
звідки походить їхня пластикова сировина.
Німецький виробник рюкзаків GOT BAG стверджує, що його продукція -
зі справжнього океанічного пластику.
Вони співпрацюють з рибалками, які піднімають його з морських глибин.
Але цей етап виробництва досі не сертифікували. Тож хто знає,
чи справді йдеться про океанічний пластик.
Те, що нам достеменно відомо: ресайклінг для підприємців -
це лише остання альтернатива. Але вилучати пластик з моря
або з місцевості поблизу моря - замість виробництва нового -
це все одно виграш для довкілля.
Хоч і не такий, як прагнуть нас переконати окремі компанії.
Отож, будьте уважні до того, що ви купуєте.
Читайте написане маленьким текстом. Не бійтеся ставити незручні запитання.
Інакше ваші добрі наміри так і залишаться намірами.